My contributions
just to,
you know,
look at new technology products that
come along,
pick out what I do,
I think are the most interesting ones.
And try to tell a fairly large group of
readers whether I think they're worth
buying.
I don't want to overinflate it.
That's what I do.
The other thing I do is I explain some
of these technologies.
Some of my comms are not product
reviews,
but they are,
uh,
planers about technology.
And then I,
a few times a year I do comms where I
take on broader issues like I,
you know,
attack the,
what I consider to be the excessive
control of the phone,
wireless phone companies,
and I'll take them on.
And that gets me to be kind of
controversial for a few weeks,
you know.
Oh.
Um,
uh,
but that's my role.
I wouldn't,
uh,
you know,
inflated.
I'm a,
I'm a journalist.
I'm a reviewer.
Uh,
I have,
uh,
thankfully I'm grateful for it.
I have a good,
large following.
And so,
uh,
I just help people sort through the,
the thicket of these technology options
they have.
But I don't invent technology.
I don't create technology
and I don't,
uh,
you know,
monetize technology.
I write about it.
Well,
I'm not going to,
cause I'm not going to buy into the idea
that I could make and break
people.
Obviously the Wall Street Journal is
widely read our websites and I'm now
all,
I'm now on many different websites,
syndicated,
uh,
I'm running my own with a partner,
Kara swisher website called the all
things d.
Dot com.
So I obviously,
because I have a lot of readers,
if I say this product is really good,
it helps them.
If I say it's really bad,
it hurts them.
But that's different than saying you can
make and break products.
I'm also not going to say I'm central to
the development.
I've never invented anything except a
co,
a column and a conference.
I've never been in any tech products.
But I think if you're asking me why have
I developed a following and been able to
retain a following,
which I do admit I have done,
I think it's because,
uh,
I've stayed true to the mission that I
proposed 16 years ago.
I don't,
I don't mean to be goofy about it,
but uh,
but sometimes the simple principles are
what works and I've just been laser
focused on,
okay,
a very specific but large audience,
which is non techies.
People who don't want to be techies,
people who have better things to do with
their time than tweaking these digital
devices.
They want them to work,
they want to enjoy them,
they want to use them.
They're not afraid of them.
They're not new to them.
They could be any age.
I mean,
you know,
if you're 16 and you have a lot of time
on your hands,
you may want to screw around with trying
to fix your windows when it breaks.
If you're the same person in your 25 and
you still are not afraid of the computer
and you have a lot of technical
knowledge,
you suddenly find you have a lot less
time on your hands to goof around with
it.
And so it isn't a question of being dumb
or smart or,
or intimidated or not intimidated.
It's a question of you bought,
you bought the laptop.
When you open it up,
you expect it to come on,
you expect it to connect to the Wifi
network,
you expect it to get you to the website,
you expect it to deal with your email,
expect to be able to play,
you know,
uh,
your favorite game on it.
You expect to be able to,
uh,
deal.
We'll do facebook and my space and at
the same time,
if you want to or need to,
you expect to be,
uh,
you know,
write a 50 page paper on it.
That's what they promise you when they
sell you the computer and they don't
promise you that you're going to be
spending your time dealing with
defragging,
the hard drive and you know,
updating the security program and all
that other stuff.
And so I have been laser focused on
that.
The first line of my first column was
personal computers are just too hard to
use and it's not your fault.
And I still think that's true and I
think,
uh,
it's true for a cell phones,
which are like personal computers 10
years ago.
It's true for,
um,
most of these products.
So,
uh,
I think that's why I still have a
following.
I mean,
I'm in widely read print and web and
broadcast outlets,
but I also constantly have adopted that
voice.
Interesting.